l'équipe qui sera joué ce match quand on
fait un bond qui remet en cause la
taille vous allez me le gagner peut-être
plaisir et on me l'a gagné avec la
manière et aujourd'hui et puis je vous
préviens aujourd'hui si on perd c'est la
défaite est allée à l'histoire était
capitaine pas leur seul à aller ça
marche comme malaisien également le
panache et bleu parce que si on perd
c'est la dénégation un ide division de
promotion de ligue et mal et ça c'est la
honte ce qui sépare région pour générer
et ça je vous acceptez qui a résonné
dans toi tu as fais au sein du roman je
serai comme un lâche façonné par la
victoire mais nos cages et ça se vend du
commun c'est demain que le gain du match
de lundi
je ris et que lourdes mais quand je dis
c'est devant sceller sa vague qui
voleraient de la serre mais comme on l'a
gagné parce qu'aujourd'hui on le savait
on est chez nos jeunes et celle
d'aujourd'hui
moi j'ai regardé au pas lent les
châteaux alors alors ces dates des
premiers à mener on va tout péter
regardez où les coeurs de jésus vous
voilà prête pour le fresh tant qu'à la
longue retraite d'ancien promotionnelle
est imminent 1114 points bas surprise
alors messieurs chats écrasés craint
l'eau froide et alors on ne m'a pas
laissé commencé à nous faire la musique
que le premier atout soigneur tout
honneur et on commençait le 1er et alors
on va leur mettre un point sur les yeux
aux tripes et au safran français de
défigurer et des premiers ronds peu
marne et les antidotes discussions avec
les tops occupait depuis que temps pour
moi tu causé par la chaussée roulante
ravoux fait et on le fait
questionnez vous sauver on m'a cherché
on a été ridicules
en effet le payer et ségolène on les
voit toujours pas c'est votre affaire
parce qu'ils sont plus rapides que les
nôtres c'est facile de connaître le dit
quand plus rapide mais aujourd'hui ils
sont chez nous arrivons noir ils vont
faire une sur place avant de rater
aujourd'hui montaner et on voit aussi
ses commandes courir les crampons dans
le dos
on m'avait pas compris la rue
aujourd'hui je veux pas voir un vilain
geste et va pas un seul village est
aujourd'hui devant l'arbitré la consigne
les matchs flair-play bon désarticule
une petite forêt autrement qu'il parle à
l'occasion le marbre action dégagés
retraite ont droit à quelques noix temps
du menuisier le 6è et l'opportunité de
doubler mais après on sait ce que c'est
pas vous mourrez nous mettez les
expulser de robes et de christophe toute
façon qui sait qu'on les musulmans comme
le métier tu t'occupes au niveau local
aujourd'hui tu t'occupes cadart jatte
equi'sol il est isolé que jamais la nuit
ouais je tiens bon la banquise à la rue
et le gard haute-garonne tu voleras pas
de sa porte parole
en parlant des fins palais à moi et
qu'ils ont la wii et agression aussi le
temps de mesurer d'assumer un designer
qui a fait votre chalet et dont les
bruins ou curieux se vaut et dont il a
pu choper un salaire s'ils voulaient
apprendre à bien dès aujourd'hui on n'y
a pas d'autre blessé chez nous - parce
que s'est il passé
bon attention aujourd'hui j'expire c'est
bon programme aujourd'hui aux remises à
votre plein de l'hyper aucune il capte
et le crochet pour le talonneur
shakespeare ses partenaires warluzel
j'expire mais ça se verra - louis sur le
maillot rouge tu est allé en libye et
appelle la police par jeu sympa afin de
mieux les causes de cure aux bourses
étaient là pour faire leur écoute non
agir pour faire le trajet pendant huit
ans doit partager le 10 mai l'eau salée
si le reporter syrienne
oui bon je reconnais pas mon rôle de
métro score peu moins longue
coucou petit nez rouge est un manager
n'est pas directement m je sais mon fils
a touché un patio qui lance celui qui
vous a pris tous les matches aller alors
aujourd hui entre nous on fait tactique
au numéro une tâche dès que je voulais
non article lu et rouge drapée dans
l'appareil mais craig à l'entraînement
vous devriez un vrai problème comme le
vote illégal et qui sont heureux où l'on
va faire un laser a4
si jamais le mec la part d'acteurs le
fou le tac tic tac tac je voudrais tu as
volé non alors tactique lors de vos
soirées et laurent delaunay sauter tout
seul quant aux parties que le rejoins
ton face aux terrains compris celles qui
sont non fondées et l'image
voilà locaux de la société tout seul au
moment où l'autre 5e fini par descendre
et à l'otan adapté de john le rouge
comme sur manège
[Applaudissements]
ainsi que leurs hôtes en utilisant la
touche tu fais passer par des critères
généreux la tentation jeu où certains
bureaux ne pardonne rien d'aller à la
sortie je suis du cours mondial à la
cacahuète promotions soldes à agir si
via la passe de touché sa mule entre 5
sur le frère lui et je veux gagner mais
toutes nos familles agenaises ses
partenaires l'antalgique aussi derrière
les attaques ont fait près du métro t on
du côté se guérir mercredi entraînait on
vous le fait voler non retirer un
entretien au bureau le feu solide en
attaque de partout on est chez nous mais
ça vient de chez nous on le sait qu'on
est chez nous et n'ont donc relevé que
deux partout alors attention petit
caillou l'ouverture est le premier bon
ballon d'attaqué que tu as tu eu la
foudre à neuchâtel
savané et de dire au muy dans les yeux
sa réception et au miroir et rien au
débat et au point de vue des jeux et
rochers pas de quartier
brad génocide mortelle de kuurne
bourthes et et puis s'en vont car les
réponses données aux rapatriés
sanitaires
je vous demande d'être présent l'un des
phases et parce que sur le moment pas se
laisser abuser par ces basses et entre
deux équipes sans venir jouer chez nous
comme chez lui mais oui j'aimerais
pouvoir les supporter depuis ce matin et
on passe on les vit dans la peur couzier
qui fait cet été aux besoins de tous et
en cette veillée devait travailler
normalement n'est pas au match est ramon
n'est pas aujourd'hui on se sert frau se
protéger d'entrée on leur fait faire de
la ligne maginot le mur l'atlantique la
muraille de chine
elle aurait encore sauvé rapport on l'a
on se protège farouche imprenable entre
autres alain vertus africaines
toutefois ces jeunes ont un super g
d'éléments extérieurs qui m'est arrivé à
la semaine est une nouvelle bon je leur
offrais il est allé voir des gosses de
curieux cours de l'image festival
investit dans mon radio comme il invite
alors à style est allé le voir je vous
ferai à pied bon mot faire et il m'a
téléphoné dans la semaine il remarque
c'est lui qu'on a plus ou moins quand
vous faire le capitaine vous n'allez pas
me croire
alors qu'il fallait que les gosses de
kurdes ou trois images qui vont jouer
noir de couleur on board emb le tuning
et où il ya plus aimés et devient
difficile que je produisais mamouni
était en panne comme le défend mais
comment tu es un moule est occupé
personnellement de la conférence est
évoquée ni rays un argentin un oeil aux
millions d'hommes pour faire le peut-il
alors oui c'est le nam nam vous allez me
le surveiller comme le lait sur le feu
les jeunes de camara 4 bd rom et
salvateur tapé le mur et manger le pire
vient de tomber notre pays oui oui
natation et d'imagés après cinq minutes
en fait 2h il aura mr leurs tickets
vendus
quel numéro il assénait mais celle là
mais je te dis que ce n'est pas un
mauvais numéro 9 pour le volet
trois humanitaires de l'onu se prennent
dès qu'ils se prennent en main alors
c'est quoi c'est fort fayard aussi
intervenir l'émirat sur le surveiller ce
qu'est ce que tu vas au jeu le voleur
qui font sensation au lieu de tuer rose
c'est l'épaule
hormis le nom de brad pitt et sa grosse
voix la nature en hausse sauf la bourgui
autre interne est pas comme ça et
évidemment ce sondage devant le comité
plutôt qu'elle se situe c'est cela qui
avait été comme gens dans mon ange
égaillera stay or sfr qui soigne les
impositions moyens nous en souvenir la
même maison
je me sens comme si j'avais de design
assez d'herbe qui savent bien je
rappelle me juillet dans le chapitre 11
ça va mieux c'est énorme et ça fait rien
on n'est pas chez toi ça valait 1 159 et
ses mouvements mais sans forcément on
faisait de la femme la vallée à l'est
les a mis en examen portent rien de
connu et war ça que je dis sur le
terrain écrit arbitre o parra et
écriture du canton entre nous
et pourtant les niçois et les pour le
prix le plus jeune et ça marche
oui la plus jeune tous les l'image si
vous voulez sandwich au pâté l'appui
jour leurs nerfs et vous fait défaut
depuis deux mois je vais mettre un peu
d'ordre là non oui mais jean moulin
d'avoir pu gagner 22 novembre voyez
comme ça n'a jamais rien qu'en plus on
n'en est rien
ouais l e conditions pendant toute la
saison pour savoir si on a gagné le
match tu es aux marchands de vous fier
au premier chef d'un journal a martian
bouger parce que tu as été signé par les
deux banques de données noah supporters
pourquoi le mieux aux qualités parmi les
grands ports et mettra à l'essai mais on
y va
[Musique]